THANK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BAY
BACKER MARGINS BRADFORD
CABALLERO CORTESE DALLY DOT
DURACELL EGGMAN GLAZER GONZALEZ
GROW HERTZBERG WHEN I FOUND HER
TADO JONES KAMLAGER LAYERED
LEYVA LIMÓN MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MEN
NEWMAN NIELSEN OR SHOW OF OAK
PAN PORTANTINO ROCK RUBIO
SKINNER STERN AMBERG BY CAL SKI
WIENER WILK. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING I QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH
THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BE ON
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS MORNING BY CENTER
DRAWS- AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
BY SENATOR DOT CENTER DRAWS-
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT. GOD OF
ALL PEOPLES AND NATIONS. TODAY
REMEMBER THAT SINGLE IN MY-
COMMEMORATES THE MEXICAN VICTORY
OVER SUPERIOR FRENCH FORCES. AT
THE BATTLE OF PUEBLA ON MAY
FIFTH EIGHTEEN SIXTY TWO. AND WE
HONOR THE HOPE AND DETERMINATION
OF THE MEXICAN PEOPLE THEN AND
NOW. AS WE CELEBRATE CINCO THE
MILD TODAY WHILE WE ENJOY THE
MUSIC AND FOOD. MAY WE
APPRECIATE THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
MEXICAN CULTURE. AND AREAS OF
BUSINESS POLITICS SCIENCE
TECHNOLOGY. RELIGION ART AND
MUCH MORE. WE PRAY THAT IN ALL
OUR CURRENT CHALLENGES WE WILL
NOT GIVE UP WHEN FAILURE APPEARS
IMMINENT. MAY WE COUNT ON OUR
INTERNAL STRENGTH. AND THE POWER
OF YOUR PRESENCE. MAY WE ALL
WORK TOGETHER TO BUILD A SOCIETY
OF EQUITY AND JUSTICE. AS WE
STRIVE TO DEFEND THOSE WHO NEED
YOUR PROTECTION STRENGTH AND
ENCOURAGEMENT. WE INVITE YOUR
HEALING PRESENCE IN THE FACE OF
ALL EARTHLY TROUBLES PAST
PRESENT AND TO COME EGGMAN. WITH
THAT BEAUTIFUL PRAYER IN OUR
MINDS AND OUR HEARTS PLEASE JOIN
ME IN A PLEDGE TO OUR FLAG. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE. SONG. THANK YOU
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO PRIVILEGES
OF THE FLOOR. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF WE CAN BRING OUR
ATTENTION TO THE FLOOR PLEASE WE
HAVE I GUESS- JOINING US THIS
MORNING WE'RE GOING TO RECOGNIZE
CENTER CABALLERO FIRST- TO
INTRODUCE AND GUESTS SHE HAS IN
THE GALLERY CENTER CABALLERO.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
IN TWO THOUSAND TWO AB TEN FORTY
FIVE WAS SIGNED INTO LAW TO TEST
AN APPROACH THAT WOULD PROVIDE
IMMEDIATE AND MEASURABLE RELIEF
TO CREATE ACCESS TO PREVENTATIVE
MEDICAL HEALTH CARE. THE BILL
WAS CREATED HAS CREATED THE
DOCTORS FROM MEXICO PILOT
PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THIRTY DOCTORS
FROM MEXICO WHO MEET SPECIFIC
CRITERIA TO PRACTICE MEDICINE IN
FEDERALLY FUNDED COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS IN FARMWORKERS
COMMUNITIES THE PROGRAM WAS
DESIGNED TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEMS
WITH ACCESS. TO CULTURALLY
COMPETENT PRIMARY METAL MEDICAL
CARE AND THE EVER WORSENING
HEALTH DISPARITIES AFTER MANY
EXHAUSTIVE YEARS ABOUT TWO
DECADES IN FACT WE FINALLY HAVE
REACHED THE STAGE WHERE OUR
PHYSICIANS ARE HERE. BELIEVE IT
OR NOT IT TOOK TWENTY YEARS THEY
ARE READY TO SERVE PATIENTS
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES WHO NEED
HELP THE MOST TODAY I AM REALLY
EXCITED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THOSE WHO
ARE HERE IN THE GALLERY TODAY.
THE DOCTORS FROM MEXICO PROGRAM
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
PROVIDING A WARM SENATE WELCOME
TO THESE DOCTORS AND EXTEND OUR
SINCEREST APPRECIATION AS WELL
AS OUR GRATITUDE. BEAR HERE
TODAY TO HELP CALIFORNIA ADDRESS
OUR NEED FOR PRIMARY HEALTH CARE. WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE WE'RE HONORED THAT
YOU'RE JOINING US HERE THIS
MORNING.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR WHICH WILL BE
DEEMED READ. MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS ARE GOING TO
MOVE TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES PURSUANT TO SENATE
RULE TWENTY NINE TEN C. THE
FOLLOWING BILLS REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON RULES FILE ITEM
EIGHTY SIX. AB FOUR TWENTY ONE
ARE HERE ANY MEMBERS WISHING TO
BE RECOGNIZED FOR MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS CENTER I'M BURKE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED- THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND THE
SENATERULES AND TAKE ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY FIVE. OUT OF ORDER.
SEEING NO OBJECTION THE MOTION
IS ADOPTED. SENATE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED. MA'AM WERE GONNA MOVE
THIS MORNING WE HAVE. THE THINGS
TO DO. A IF WE CAN BRING YOUR TO
THE PLEASE OUT BE GREATLY WE'RE
GONNA GO THE KEY OF THE DAILY
FILE SIGNATURE PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILLS TEN EIGHTY FIVE
WITH AMENDMENTS ELEVEN FIFTY
FIVE WITH AMENDMENTS TWELVE
SEVENTY NINE WITH AMENDMENTS
THIRTEEN EIGHTY WITH AMENDMENTS.
ELEVEN EIGHTEEN WITH AMENDMENTS
SENATE BILL. TEN THIRTY FIVE TEN
SEVENTY NINE TWELVE SIXTY
THIRTEEN TWENTY THREE TEN TWENTY
FOUR. ELEVEN FIFTY NINE FOURTEEN
OH FIVE. AND ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU MA'AM
SECRETARY MEMBERS WERE GONNA
MOVE TO ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
OR TAKING UP FILE ITEM THIRTEEN
AB THIRTY FIVE. WE'RE GOING TO
RECOGNIZE CENTER- BURKE TO
PRESENT THE OPENING ON AB THIRTY
FIVE FILE ITEM THIRTEEN. WE'LL
WAIT TILL WE HAVE EVERYBODY'S
ATTENTION. CENTER NUMBER YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. I GOT AHEAD
OF MYSELF SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES AN ACT
RELATING TO CIVIL DAMAGES.
CENTER OF OUR THANK YOU MISS
PRESENT I CAN UNDERSTAND YOUR
HASTE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE TAKE THIS UP BEFORE SOMEONE
CHANGES THEIR MIND ON THIS
HISTORIC COMPROMISE- I AM
PLEASED PRIVILEGE AND HONOR TO
BE ABLE TO PRESENT AB THIRTY
FIVE ON BEHALF OF MYSELF AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAYOS- THIS BILL
REPRESENTS A LONG OVERDUE REFORM
TO THE MEDICAL INJURY
COMPENSATION REFORM ACT. KNOWN
AS MICRO. IT'S BEEN UNCHANGED
FOR NEARLY FIVE DECADES- JUST AS
A POINT OF PERSONAL PRIVILEGE
WHEN I THINK BACK TO WHEN I
FIRST CAME THE LEGISLATURE
THIRTY TWO YEARS AGO. THIS WAS A
BIG ISSUE THIRTY TWO YEARS AGO
AND IT HAS REMAINED SUCH. THE
LAST. TEAM DECADES AND I THINK
BACK ON THOSE WHO. ATTEMPTED TO
IN SOME WAY MODIFY IT SOME WAY
REFORM IT SENATORS LOCKYER IN A
BIRDIE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS-
EISENBERG. SPEAKER WILLIE BROWN-
THIS IS A COMPROMISE THAT
PROVIDES A BALANCED EQUITABLE
SOLUTION FOR PATIENTS AND
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS. WILL KEEP
HEALTH CARE ACCESSIBLE AND
AFFORDABLE WELL BOUNCE
APPROPRIATE COMPENSATION FOR
CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCING HEALTH
CARE RELATED INJURY OR DEATH.
THIS BILL EXTEND THE LONG TERM
PREDICTABILITY AND AFFORDABILITY
OF MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL
LIABILITY INSURANCE FOR THOSE
PROVIDING MEDICAL CARE IN
CALIFORNIA AND PROVIDE A FAIR
AND REASONABLE INCREASE THE
LIMITS ON NON ECONOMIC DAMAGES
IN MEDICAL NEGLIGENCE. CASES
CURRENT LAW. AND DOLLARS NON
ECONOMIC DAMAGES REGARDLESS OF
THE NUMBER OF DEFENDANTS THIS
BILL INCREASES THE CAP FOR NON
DEATH CASES FROM TWO R.
500-003-0050 THOUSAND AND
CONTINUES TO INCREASE. THAT
CEILING TO SIMILAR FIFTY
THOUSAND OVER TEN YEARS. THE CAP
FOR WRONGFUL DEATH CASES WOULD
INCREASE FOR FROM TWO R. FIFTY
THOUSAND TO. FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND AND CONTINUES TO
INCREASE TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
AFTER TEN YEARS SUBSEQUENT TO
THE CAP INCREASES IN TWENTY
THIRTY THREE A 2% COLO WILL KICK
IN STARTING JANUARY ONE TWENTY
THIRTY FOUR AND WE'LL JUST THE
CAPS. ANNUALLY WILL ALSO
ESTABLISH NEW DISCOVERING
EVIDENCE YOU PROTECTION FOR ALL
PRE LITIGATION EXPRESSIONS OF
SYMPATHY REGRET OR BENEVOLENCE
INCLUDING STATEMENTS OF FALL BY
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS SO FOR
EXAMPLE IF THE PHYSICIAN SHOULD.
EXPRESSED SYMPATHY FOR AN
INJURED INDIVIDUAL THAT THAT IS
EXCLUDED. FROM EVIDENCE SB
THIRTY FIVE ALSO CREATES THREE
SEPARATE CATEGORIES OF
DEFENDANTS. FOUR THREE POSSIBLE
CAPS ONE CAP FOR HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS ONE CAP FOR HEALTHCARE
INSTITUTIONS ONE CAP FOR AN
UNAFFILIATED HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER HEALTH CARE INSTITUTION
COMMITS A SEPARATE NEGLIGENT
ACT. THE BILL HAS PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY UNANIMOUSLY THROUGH
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND HAS NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION I WANT TO
JUST TAKE A MOMENT TO THANK
THOSE WHO WOULD WORK SO HARD- IN
SO WELL. IN ACHIEVING THIS
COMPROMISE THE- CALIFORNIANS
ALLIED FOR PATIENT PROTECTION
THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND CERTAIN INDIVIDUALS WHO
REALLY DESERVE RECOGNITION.
MISTER NICK RILEY- AND CHARLES
JOHNSON LEADERS OF THE FAIRNESS
FOR INJURED. PATIENTS INITIATIVE
DR ROBERT WALES PRESENTLY
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
MISS LISA MAAS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIANS
ALLOWED. PER PATIENT PROTECTION
GREG CAMPBELL LEE IN TRENTON AND
OF COURSE NANCY TRAVELING CRAIG
PETERS LEADERS OF THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA- THIS
WILL GO DOWN AS SOMETHING THAT
WILL ALL REMEMBER WE PASSED
THOUSANDS OF BILLS THOUSANDS OF
BILLS AND ONLY BUT A HANDFUL ARE
THOSE THAT CHANGE CALIFORNIANS
IN DRAMATIC WAYS AND THIS IS ONE
OF THEM. I ORIGINAL VOTE. THANK
YOU CENTER ABERG OPENING
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE. SENATOR
RUBIO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE TODAY I
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY FIVE AS A CO AUTHOR. FOR
DECADES POLICY MAKERS AND
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE WORKED AND
STRUGGLE TO REACH AN AGREEMENT
ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE ON HOW
TO BEST PROTECT PATIENTS. THIS
YEAR WE ARE ACCOMPLISHING
REMARKABLE WORK. I'M STILL
ENCOURAGED BY THIS COLLABORATION
AND OUR ABILITY AS CALIFORNIANS
TO SHOW THAT GOOD PUBLIC POLICY
CAN COME FROM PUTTING POLITICAL
DIFFERENCES AND USE THE SITE TO
DO THE RIGHT THING AND NOT
DOUBLING DOWN I WANT TO THANK
THE GOOD SENATOR FROM SAN. SANTA
ANA THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN AND ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS FROM CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS TO THE SEMI AND ALL
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE THIS
POSSIBLE THIS HISTORIC AGREEMENT
WILL PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF
INJURED PATIENTS AND IT ALSO
STRIKES AN IMPORTANT BALANCE TO
ENSURE LONG TERM PREDICTABILITY
AND AFFORDABILITY SO TODAY I
ENCOURAGE ALL MY COLLEAGUES ON
THIS FLOOR. TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SEEN RUBIO
CENTER PAN. THANK YOU A MISS
PRESIDENT- SENATORS- FIRST OF
ALL I WANT TO OUGHT TO WANNA
JOIN MY COLLEAGUES IN THANKING
THE- DEFENSE TO CAME UP WITH
THIS VERY IMPORTANT HISTORIC
TREATMENT- IN RELATION TO-
DRESSING- LIABILITY- IT'S AND I
HOPE THAT- YEAH AND THIS IS A-
COLLABORATION AND AGREEMENT
BETWEEN. HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
WHO TAKE CARE OF PATIENTS AND
THE TRIAL ATTORNEYS AND- I HOPE
AND- THAT- THE DISSIDENTS
AGREEMENT THEY HAVE COMMITTED
THAT THIS IS AGREEMENT DOUBLE
DOOR- SO CERTAINLY WE HEAR IN
THE LEGISLATURE HAVE HAD TO DEAL
WITH THE ONE SIDE THE OTHER-
ASKING US TO MAKE MODIFICATIONS
AND SO FORTH. BUT THIS IS A
MUTUAL AGREEMENT THAT HOPEFULLY
WILL AS AGAIN I SAY INDOOR AND
THAT SO WE WILL NOT HAVE TO SEE
A FUTURE BILLS SHOWING UP HERE-
WITHOUT A CONTRACT WITHOUT
AGREEMENT BETWEEN ALL THE
PARTIES TO AGREE TO THIS
AGREEMENT. SO I THINK THAT'S
VERY IMPORTANT. I ALSO WANT TO
MAKE NOTE THOUGH IS THAT-
CERTAINLY- IT'S IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT FIRST OF ALL
THERE WAS NEVER EVER EVEN WITH
MICRON A LIMIT ON ECONOMIC
DAMAGES. NEVER EVER EVER SO THAT
WE REMAIN ALSO CONTINUES TO RING
TRUE IN THIS AGREEMENT THE
DISAGREEMENTS LIFTING CAPS ON
NON ECONOMIC DAMAGES SO IN OTHER
WORDS WE NEED TO KEEP IN MIND
THAT PATIENTS WHEN THEY'RE
INJURED THEY WILL ALWAYS GET
FULL COMPENSATION INJURY HAD IT
BEFORE WE'LL CONTINUE TO HAVE IT
UNDER THIS AGREEMENT AS WELL SO
THAT I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
I THINK TO REMEMBER. SECOND OF
ALL YOU'LL BE HONEST AS IT IS A-
AS A PHYSICIAN- THIS WILL PUT
UPWARD PRESSURE- BECAUSE RAISING
THE CAPS ON HEALTHCARE COSTS
THIS WILL RAISE THE OVERHEAD
COST LIABILITY COSTS FOR A
CLINICS HOSPITALS AND PHYSICIANS
BUT IT DOES DO IN A WAY THAT IS-
PREDICTABLE AND MANAGEABLE IN
THE TERMS OF THIS AGREEMENT. SO
THAT WILL AUSUBEL MINIMIZE THOSE
COST PRESSURES AND COST
INCREASES AND THAT'S WHY THIS
DEALS ALSO SO VERY IMPORTANT AS
WELL- THE ALTERNATIVE WOULD HAVE
BEEN. MUCH HIGHER POTENTIALLY
HIGHER INCREASES AND LESS
PREDICTABLE ONES WHICH I COULD
PUT A MAJOR PRESSURE ESPECIALLY
AS WE'RE STRUGGLING WITH TRYING
TO CONTROL HEALTH CARE COSTS SO
THIS DEAL DOES ACHIEVE. I WELL
CERTAINLY HAS CERTAIN EFFECTS IT
CERTAINLY IS ONE THAT WILL LEAD
TO. A BETTER SOLUTION MOVING
FORWARD. AND AGAIN WANT TO THANK
THE PARTIES WHO CAME TOGETHER TO
MAKE THIS AGREEMENT. AND
CERTAINLY- WILL BE SUPPORTING IT
HERE TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR PATTERSON EARLIER. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR PRESIDENT I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE HISTORY THAT CAME
FROM CHAIR ON BURKE ON THIS- I
HAD MY OWN HISTORY WHICH IS WHEN
I WENT TO WORK FOR THE COUNTY OF
SANTA CRUZ IS THE HEALTH ANALYST
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR. WE
WERE IN THE MIDDLE OF HAVING
PHYSICIANS IN OUR AREA GOLDEN
BEAR WITHOUT INSURANCE AND WE IN
FACT HAD A WE HAD TO HIRE NURSES
MIDWIVES IS COUNTY NURSE
MIDWIVES BECAUSE THERE WERE
OBGYN IS THAT WE'RE GOING OUT
WITHOUT INSURANCE AND THAT THE
ACTUAL DELIVERY OF SERVICE WAS
THREATENED. AND THERE OF COURSE
HAS BEEN A DEBATE ABOUT. WHETHER
THAT WAS A MANIPULATION OF THE
MARKET OR THAT WAS GENUINE
BOUGHT IT WAS WHAT WAS
HAPPENING. AND SO THE MARKET CAP
WAS AGREED TO AS A COMPROMISE
THEN. AND YET. OF THE COMPROMISE
WAS THE TWO HUNDRED AND R. FIFTY
THOUSAND CAP ON THE PORTION THAT
WAS MENTIONED AND YET IF YOU
LOOK AT WHAT THE ECONOMIC VALUE
OF THAT TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND IS NOW. IT IS ROUGHLY
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS AND SO
WHILE THERE'S NO LIMIT ON THE
ECONOMIC DAMAGES THE WOMEN ON
THIS PART WAS KEEPING PEOPLE
FROM GETTING REPRESENTATION THAT
WAS THE REAL ISSUE THAT HAPPENED
HERE. AND FOR THOSE OF US
SITTING ON THIS FLOOR. WE HAD
THE ISSUES OF- WHEN I WAS IN A
LEGISLATIVE RACE IN TWENTY TEN.
JUST THE FACT THAT I SAID THIS
SHOULD BE INDEXED AS A CAP LED
TO A MAJOR INDEPENDENT
EXPENDITURE AGAINST ME IN THAT
RACE. WHEN I WAS RUNNING A YEAR
AND A HALF AGO I BASICALLY SAID.
WE SHOULD MOVE ON THIS UNLESS
EVERYONE'S IN THE TABLE AND THAT
IS WHAT JUST HAPPENED. AND SO IN
SALUTING EVERYBODY FOR THIS I
THINK THE INTERESTING THING IS.
IS THIS WAS KEPT A SECRET AS
LONG AS IT WAS THIS IS
SACRAMENTO AMAZINGLY IT DIDN'T
FLOAT OUT THERE THAT THESE
NEGOTIATIONS WERE GOING ON FOR A
LONG TIME. AND THAT IS
SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE I THINK IF
IT HAD. IT WOULD HAVE BEEN HARD
FOR SOME OF THE PLAYERS. TO HOLD
THEIR PEOPLE IN LINE. AND IT
GAVE THEM A CHANCE ONCE A DEAL
WAS REACHED TO CONVINCE THEM
THAT THIS WAS IN THEIR LONG TERM
INTEREST. AND WHEN WE WERE IN
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. OUR
HEART WAS ALL PREPARED TO SPEAK
TO OPPONENTS AND I THOUGHT THERE
WOULD BE RANDOM OPPONENTS THAT
FOR DIFFERENT REASONS BECAUSE OF
THEIR OWN INTERESTS THOUGHT THAT
THEY COULDN'T SUPPORTERS. BUT
WHEN THE CHAIR CALLED FOR
WITNESSES THERE WAS NOBODY IN
THE ROOM AND THERE WAS NOBODY ON
THE PHONE LINE. THAT IS
MONUMENTAL BUT SOMETHING THAT IS
THIS BIG DOES NOT HAVE ANY REAL
OPPOSITION. AND THEN I
APPRECIATE- OF THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS NAMING WHO WAS INVOLVED
IN THIS BECAUSE I THINK. FOR THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS AND FOR THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN PARTICULAR HELLO. A
CALIFORNIANS ALLIED FOR
PROTECTION. WERE ALSO
SIGNIFICANTALONG WITH EVERYONE
AND THE DOCTORS COMPANY-
CONSUMER WATCH HANDS OF THE
PROPONENT OF THE BALLOT MEASURE
WELL I THINK. AS MUCH AS WE LIKE
TO THINK THAT ABOUT MEASURE
DOESN'T FORCE A SOLUTION IT
REALLY HELPED. AND THE REFORM
THAT THE LEGISLATURE MADE. TO
REALLY ALLOW FOR SOMEBODY TO
PULL BACK AN INITIATIVE. REALLY
WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN MAKING THIS
HAPPEN IF THAT WASN'T THERE- SO
THAT RIGHT NOW IN THIS ACROSS
THE BOARD AGREEMENT. WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO PULL IT OFF THE
BALLOT FOR LEAST DOWNPLAY IT IN
A WAY THAT'S VERY SIGNIFICANT SO
THIS IS A BIG AND I THINK THAT.
THE TERROR ATTACKS FREQUENTLY
THAT THE LEGISLATURE OR STATE
GOVERNMENT DOESN'T WORK THIS IS
REALLY AN INSTANCE WHERE TRULY
WORKS WERE WERE HAVING A LONG
TERM SOLUTION. THAT'S OF BENEFIT
TO ALL THE PARTIES THAT IS GOING
TO REMOVE ONE OF THE MOST
CONTENTIOUS ISSUES. IN STATE
GOVERNMENT FROM THE TABLE SO I
SALUTE EVERYBODY THAT WORKED ON
THIS I AM REALLY PROUD TO BE A
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE
. THANK YOU CENTER LAYER SENATOR
NIELSEN. MR PRESIDENT LADIES
AND- THE SENATE I HAS COME AT
THIS FROM KIND OF A UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE. I SPENT MY CAREER
DEFENDING MICRO. HAVING BEEN
ALMOST KILLED BY THE THERE ONE
TIME. BUT WHAT MY WIFE AND I HAD
NO INTENTION OF FILING A LAWSUIT
. I WAS VERY VESTED IN THE
HEALTH CARE INSTITUTION MY
COMMUNITY. AND THE BILL PROBLEMS
I BECAME A VICTIM. BUT WE WANT
TO WORK TO IMPROVE THE WHOLE
SYSTEM FOR EVERYBODY. RATHER
THAN THE NONSENSE WELL I'M USING
THE WRONG WORD BUT- A LAWSUIT.
THEN I FEEL JUST A TINY BIT
BETRAYED BY THIS COMPROMISE WHY
. BECAUSE I PROBABLY LONGER THAN
ANYBODY HAVE DEFENDED MICRO. I
UNDERSTAND THE CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT HAS FOSTERED THIS
COMPROMISE. AND IT PROBABLY HAS
MERIT WITH THE EXCEPTION OF THE
INDEXING OF 2% A YEAR. I DON'T
LIKE INDUCTION. IT'S VERY
PROBLEMATIC. AND THAT'S
AUTOMATIC AS WELL. BUT I WOULD
SAY WE SHOULD BE CAUTIOUS AND I
MAY BE A PROBLEM THE ONLY ONE SO
VOICES MY OPINION ON THIS. BUT
MICRO HAS SERVED US WELL OVER
THE DECADES MAYBE IT IS INDEED A
NEW TIME. AND I PROBABLY SHOULD
BE ONE OF THE MOST ENTHUSIASTIC
SUPPORTERS. BUT TODAY I WILL BE
A NOBLE. THANK YOU SENATOR
NELSON SENATOR HOOKED HER TADO.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY AS A
PROUD CO AUTHOR BABY THIRTY FIVE
. I FIRST BECAME INTERESTED IN
IN THIS AREA BECAUSE OF SOME
CONSTITUENTS- MY FIRST YEAR IN
OFFICE THAT BROUGHT TO MY
ATTENTION THAT. THERE WASN'T AND
WE'VE KNOWN THIS TO BE TRUE IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY QUALITY CARE
. AND WHEN I GOT MORE INVOLVED
AND LEARN MORE ABOUT THE STORIES
I LEARNED THAT. THERE IS A LOT
OF ISSUES THAT WE NEEDED TO DO
TO FIX. AND JUST REALLY
UNFORTUNATE UP. STORIES THAT
INDIVIDUALS YOUNG WOMAN COULD
STILL BE ALIVE TODAY HAD WE IN
PLACE A. B. A SYSTEM OF HEALTH
CARE IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
IMPROBABLY PERHAPS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THAT
PROVIDES QUALITY CARE- INCLUDING
AND DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
AND FOR THIS REASON I BEEN VERY
MUCH IN FAVOR OF CREATING
CHANGES SO THAT. WE PREVENT HARM
IN THE FIRST PLACE THAT WE
PREVENT MISTAKE IN THE FIRST
PLACE BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE
DAY IT'S ABOUT. GETTING QUALITY
CARE AND IF WE PROVIDE THE
RESOURCES AND THE EDUCATION AND
THE TRAINING AND EVERYTHING THAT
WE NEED I MEAN IT BENEFITS
EVERYONE. SO I THINK THAT THIS
BILL IF SOMEONE IS INJURED OR
DIES AS A RESULT OF KEROPPI BUT
THE RECEIVED THEIR FAMILY SHOULD
BE ENTITLED TO A REASONABLE
COMPENSATION. EVEN THOUGH THERE
IS NO AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT CAN
BRING BACK A LOVED ONE. OR
REBUILD. EIGHT EIGHT IN LIFE- AB
THIRTY FIVE REALLY. AB EIGHT
INCREASES ABOUT THE FAMILIES AND
PATIENTS MAY RECEIVE A NON
ECONOMIC DAMAGES IT A NUMBER
THAT HAS BEEN INCREASED FOR. YOU
KNOW THE HAS BEEN INCREASED FOR
NEARLY FIFTY YEARS INCREASING
THESE CAPS ARE NOT IT IT'S
TIMELY BUT IT'S ALSO THE RIGHT
THING TO DO AND- I'M PLEASED TO
BE VOTING IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL TODAY AND I RESPECTFULLY
RESPUESTAS SUPPORTED AS WELL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER TADO
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE KING. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT OF FIRST OFF
FOR ALL THE CANDIDATES NOW IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY TWENTY SIX.
YOU'RE WELCOME. YOU'RE WELCOME
BECAUSE THEY WILL NOT KNOW WHAT
IT WAS LIKE IT TOO MANY OF US
HERE THAT WHAT IS MICRO AND WHAT
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT AND WHAT
DID THESE WARRING FACTIONS. THAT
THEY JUST WILL NOT HAVE A CLUE
SO YOU'RE WELCOME. THE SECOND
POINT IS THAT IS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SANTA CRUZ SAID THIS IS A
BIG DEAL AND RAISING THE NON
ECONOMIC. IN AMOUNTS IS HUGE
BECAUSE WE- TEACH WE TREAT LIFE
WE TREAT IT. ENTRY THE SAME BUT
- I WANT TO THANK EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU BECAUSE WE WERE
THE ONES THAT PASSED THE
MEASURE. THAT REQUIRED THIS
BALLOT INITIATIVE TO COME BACK
TO US THAT WAS A LITTLE STROKE
OF GENIUS AND THIS IS THIS NOW
WE'RE WE'RE- LET'S. LET'S ENJOY
THE FRUITS OF OUR LABOR BECAUSE
OTHERWISE WHEN THAT BALLOT
INITIATIVE GOT GOT THE CERTIFIED
FROM THE SECRETARY OF STATE IT
WENT TO NOVEMBER IT WAS IT WAS
ON THE BALLOT. AND NOW IT'S GOT
TO COME TO US IN A CREATED THIS
MEDIATION OR THIS DISCUSSION FOR
COMPROMISE TO BE MADE STILL. FOR
THE LEAD AUTHOR CONGRATULATIONS
TO YOU AND CONGRATULATIONS
EVERYBODY IN THIS CHAMBER FOR
YOUR WISDOM AND RECALL REQUIRING
THESE BALLOT INITIATIVES TO COME
BACK AND- LET COOL HER COOLER.
IT'S RESULTED IN AYE PURGING AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SIR BYE CAL
SKINNY OTHER DISCO OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. ANY OTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON AB THIRTY FIVE
SEEING NONE CENTER NUMBER YOU
MAY CLOSE. I THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS AND THANK YOU
FOR THAT THE COMMENTS- I WANT
TO. ALIGN MYSELF WITH- MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE BAY AREA-
THIS IS A TESTAMENT TO HOW THE
PROCESS CAN WORK- NEXT AS TO MY
COLLEAGUE AND FRIEND FROM. THE
HEMA. IS SHOULD THIS NOT PASS IT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT MICROSTATES
THE SAME IT JUST MEANS THAT
THERE'S A BALLOT INITIATIVE.
HAT MUCH MORE DRAMATICALLY
CHANGES MICRO THAT IS EMBODIED
IN THIS COMPROMISE- I WOULD ASK
THAT WE HURRY INVOKED BEFORE
ANYONE CHANGES THEIR MIND IRES
NIVAL. THANK YOU CENTER NUMBER
WITH ALL THE CONFIDENCE HE HAS
IN HIS BILL SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS. AYE
BATES. AYE BECKER. AYE FORTUS.
AYE BRADFORD. AYE CABRERA. AYE
CORTESE. AYE DOLLY. AYE DODD.
FIVE ZERO SEVEN FIVE EGGMAN FIVE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW. I
HERTZBERG. WESA HYPER TADO I
JONES I KAMLAGER I LAYERED AYE
LEYVA AYE THE MON I MCGUIRE. I
MELENDEZ AYE MIN AYE NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN NO CONTROL OF BOTH AYE
PAN AYE PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
ON BURKE HI WHAT HOUSE SPEAKER.
I WIENER AYE WILK. HIGHS THIRTY
SEVEN KNOWS ONE MAJOR PASSES.
CONGRATULATIONS. MEMBERS ARE
MOVING BACK TO- PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR TODAY OR THIS MORNING-
CENTER LAYERED HAS A GUEST IN
THE GALLERY. ASSYRIAN FAITH FROM
THE CYSTIC FIBROSIS RESEARCH
INSTITUTES HERE- FOR CF
AWARENESS MONTH IF WE CAN GIVE A
WARM WELCOME TO SYRIA MAY I HEAR
ON CYSTIC FIBROSIS THANK YOU.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO MOVE TO
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS SENATOR-
BURKE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENT.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES OF FOR THOSE YOUNG
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE- WE'RE
FORTUNATE TO BE ABLE TO MEET
TODAY TWENTY MINUTES AFTER THE
END THE SESSION IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED- BE THERE- I UNDERSTAND
SHOULD WE GO PAST LUNCH THAT
THAT CENTER WINNER WILL BE
PROVIDING LUNCH SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. IN ADDITION S.
ACCIDENT SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE IN. ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED IN THE- STREET BUILDING
TWENTY MINUTES AFTER ADJOURNMENT
. IF THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS
INTERACTIONS THE DESK IS CLEAR.
MISTER PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH I. TOTALLY ENJOYING THIS
UNDERTONE OF HUMOR TODAY. I HOPE
WE CARRY IT INTO THE NEXT FEW
WEEKS BECAUSE- IT'S GONNA GET
BUSIER WE'RE GONNA HAVE A LOT OF
WORK TO DO BUT WITH THAT LET ME
JUST SAY OUR NEXT WORK SESSION
IS SCHEDULED FOR MONDAY MAY
NINE. TWENTY TWENTY TWO AT TWO
PM THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT THANK
YOU CENTER ATKINS THE SENATE
WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL THREE
THIRTY PM AT WHICH TIME THE
GERMAN MOTION WILL BE PLACED
WILL RECONVENE ON MONDAY AT TWO
PM WE ARE ADJOURNED.